narendra modi jefe de gobierno de la
india recomendó a vladimir putin detener
la invasión a ucrania la época actual no
está para guerras ante la recomendación
del premier indio uno de sus principales
aliados económicos putin lanzó una
promesa
conozco su posición respecto al
conflicto en ucrania y conozco las
preocupaciones que siempre usted expresa
haremos todo lo posible para terminar
con todo lo antes posible
pero no dejó de disparar la piedra a su
contraparte mayor en el rostro
y
desafortunadamente los líderes del lado
opuesto y ucrania han declarado que se
niegan a dialogar y que quieren alcanzar
sus objetivos militarmente o como dicen
en el campo de batalla
sin embargo apenas horas más tarde el
líder del kremlin manifestó en rueda de
prensa un discurso totalmente diferente
afirmando que para rusia la llamada
operación militar especial es progresiva
y avanza a paso lento putin mínima son
los alcances de la contraofensiva
ucraniana que ha recuperado terrenos
ocupados por rusia en las últimas
semanas lanzando una clara advertencia a
kiev
chase quiero llamar la atención ante que
no estamos luchando con todo el ejército
ruso sólo con partes específicas por
supuesto esto está relacionado con los
parámetros de nuestro ejército por lo
tanto no tenemos prisa en este aspecto
ridges en el encuentro y las
declaraciones posteriores se produjeron
en el contexto de la cumbre de la
organización de cooperación de shanghai
una reunión en la que se ha expuesto
cierta afinidad con rusia uno de los
líderes del organismo al margen de la
guerra el presidente ruso insiste en que
el objetivo principal de la incursión
militar sigue siendo el mismo la
liberación de la región del donbass sin
embargo las tropas de moscú ocupan
quinto del territorio ucraniano